[Music]
showing us exercise but also being
vulnerable and opened with audience demi
lovato is spilling on that steamy kiss
with her opening act
Kolani earlier this week the two locked
lips on stage at Lovato's Newark New
Jersey concerts
[Music]
[Applause]
and on Thursday the 25 year old pop star
opened up about the sexy moment on BBC
Radio One's The Breakfast Show with Nick
Grimshaw she came up behind me I had no
idea she told me she was going to be
watching the show so I was like looking
for and I didn't see her out there so I
was like okay I guess she'd like decided
to go or whatever and then all of a
sudden I feel hands on my shoulders for
the song called lonely and I look up and
it's hers and get this Demi says the
moment was totally spontaneous and I
don't know we just kissed each other
like it wasn't planned it what she
totally surprised me and it was just
like a perfect day Dalton Palani
responded to the moment shortly after it
all went down posting these shots on
Instagram with the caption anyone would
be stupid not to jump at the chance to
hop on that damn moving bed and grab
your face
you
[Music]